على العموم سال الناس في مصر ما هو الامر
الذي يمكن ان يتوفر في العمل لتصبح حياتك
افضل
[موسيقى]
والله انا عاوز يبقى في مرتب كويس يبقى
فيه مواصلات يبقى الدنيا دي تبقى كويسه
اللي هو الحياه اللي هي الماديه الكويسه
اللي هي تساعد على ان احنا نبني في
المرتبات مثلا ان انت بتشتغل في حاجه برده
ما بتاخذش المرتب اللي بيجزيك
مرتب كويس يقدر ان هو يفر لي حياه كريمه
ده بس انا محتاجه من صاحب العمل اه من
العمل اللي انا فيه عموما علشان يتمنى
الحياه مستقر نفسيا لي والاسره ان انت
تكون مقتنع بالعمل اللي بتاديه تدي شغلك
تدي واجبك بما يرضي الله ربنا هيكرمك سيبك
من اللي انت مستني لا مستني ده ربنا هو
اللي بيجازيك فيه
الواحد يقبض بالدولار عشان الواحد بقى
عايز يشتري تليفونات وعايز يشتري حاجات
محتاج مرطب كويس عشان نقدر نعيش في الحياه
عموما محتاج تدريبات اكثر علشان نطور من
نفسنا في الشغل ونمشي خطوه او ناخذ ستوب
حلوه لقدام بعد كده في حياتنا
[موسيقى]